this is an important day in the history
of Columbia University it's the day when
we mark Columbia's entrance into Latin
America and specifically to Chile
Colombia is opening officially on this
day and at this moment it's Latin
American global Center in Santiago Chile
this will make it possible for our
faculty and our students to engage with
chilean students and faculty to learn to
exchange ideas to exchange visits to
collaborate on research and other kinds
of projects and it will make use of
Chile's extraordinary resources human
and material julia is a country which as
you know has served as a model for much
of Latin America and economic management
and in other ways so it's entirely
appropriate that we should locate our
first global center in Latin America in
a country that so much talked about and
so important to the rest of the region
and to the United States our global
center in Chile will operate not only to
connect us to Chile but because of
Chile's presence throughout Latin
America and because of its importance of
the country we will base many of the
things we do in Latin America in other
countries in our global center office in
Santiago none of this would have been
possible without a number of key
individuals the first you will hear from
in a few moments is the president of the
University Lee Bollinger who several
years ago decided rather abruptly some
of us thought that a university like
Columbia had to engage the world and had
to embark on a transition from being an
American University with a global
reputation to being a truly global
university and the global centers as
part of that strategy have come to play
an important life an important part in
the life of our university and they will
I think become more important as the
years
the second person that I should
acknowledge and who you will hear from
shortly is Kenneth Pruitt I knew Ken
when he was president of the social
sciences research council he went on to
become director of the US Census Bureau
we haven't had as good numbers since I'd
he agreed to take on a task which Lee
Bollinger assigned to him just two years
ago that a vice president for global
centers and he is the anime spirit that
has made it possible for us to make such
enormous progress not only the Santiago
center but also global centers that are
now located in Paris in beijing in
Mumbai soon to be inaugurated in
Istanbul in Nairobi have I left anything
out Albin Jordan and today Santiago
Chile so I want to acknowledge Ken's
presence and you'll hear from him in a
moment finally I want to mention Pablo
vacatio who is professor of history and
director of the Institute for Latin
American Studies what makes these global
centers work is their connection to
faculty back at the university faculty
and students and what has been what has
been the principal presence of Latin
America at Columbia for many years 50 in
fact has been its Institute for Latin
American Studies so you will here
shortly from Pablo as well Pablo is the
second person on this panel that claims
to have been born in Chile but but let
me introduce the first I first met I
first met andronica Lucic some years ago
at a small college at north of here when
he served on the advisory committee what
is called at Harvard that David
Rockefeller Center for Latin American
Studies this was a the Advisory
Committee was composed of a number of
very distinguished citizens of latin
america in the united states and
elsewhere indeed and was a committee
full of firepower great advice and
interesting ideas but of all those who
participated in this committee the one
who was the most focused the
most force far-sighted and indeed in
many ways the most generous with his
time and resources was an Ghana kulusuk
so I want to thank him for that and also
thank him for his willingness to join
with Colombia in this new venture he is
a as we all know a man of great vision
both entrepreneurial and philanthropic
and it's a great pleasure to welcome him
back to Columbia University and running
there's no doubt that John and I are
very good friends I appreciate very much
introduction president Bollinger vice
provost Cosworth amber how atrocities
ambassadors I'm proud to be part of this
initiative which will bring one of the
most prestigious universities in the
United States to Chile the establishment
of the Columbia global centers Latin
America in santiago is an endeavor that
will undoubtedly benefit both the
university and chili my role here is to
be a facilitator and I assure you I am
very happy to be only a facilitator a
partner in a broader project to
contribute to the educational future and
development of Chile the choice that
Colombia has made to locate its Latin
America global center in Chile is a
recognition of past accomplishments and
a contribution to our future growth it
is my sincere hope that the center in
Chile will likewise provide the students
alumni and faculty of the University a
place to discuss ideas create networks
and foster the exchange of knowledge
I am proud to say that I follow my old
friend jon Cosford to New York from
cambridge and i have found through him
new friends and new opportunities to
help shape the future of my country
thank you John thank you you all thanks
a lot and now perfect professor Pablo
Picasso director of the Institute for
Latin American Studies I would like
first to clarify that I don't claim to
have been born in Chile i was born in
argentina and he's not a claim i can
produce a birth certificate but it's um
you know I would have I wouldn't mind
you know if the if the case was
different I came through Mexico so one
country sometimes it's not enough I just
want to celebrate this occasion on
behalf of ella's the Institute of Latin
American Studies we are a center that
has over 150 faculty members affiliated
to it hundreds of students we have a
master's programs we bring visiting
professors we encourage your faculty and
students to go to Latin America and you
know I think this is also something that
we should celebrate because as a
historian I see the circulation of ideas
people and and and commodities as
something integral to to the history of
the countries since independence where
they began to define each other in a
relation or expanding into each other
but connecting us countries and or
ambition as an institute and also as
collaborators or friends of of the
global center is to facilitate on
the continuities of those networks of
knowledge of research who are so
important here and in latin america as i
said we try to make everything possible
to bring people to Latin America when
they want to learn languages but when
they want to do research even if the
research is not only about Latin America
and obviously we receive people who come
to the u.s. to teach to communicate and
collaborate with other members of the
faculty and to use the resources of this
great University which is a something
very attractive for for Latin America I
can speak in the name of historians
you're not just going to pour library
such a pleasure so we know that this
these movements of people are not easy
sometimes they have a cost is not
symmetrical movement sometimes so I
think that the existence of the global
center is very important to help us even
the field and try to have a
collaboration that would be yet even
more meaningful not only for the
development of Latin American stories
but also for the the growth of the
university has a global university so
congratulations and thank you very much
thank you publié for the footnote
correcting my factual error it must be
your eloquence that lately confuse your
birthplace now vice president put
android
I when when John said that we had the
opportunity to open up the center and
chili I took a deep breath because we
were really very busy trying to swallow
the ones we had already started and and
I was hesitant and that kind of stuff
and on the other hand it's extremely
important because we cannot be a global
network until we're in Latin America and
you've now made that happen so for the
first time we really can very first time
in the history of this project we can
say we're now a global network we were
just everywhere but my my hesitancy ease
were just about the amount of work that
had to be done on the lazy kind of guy
and then in my office walk Karen cut me
a check I said my God my problems are
solved we've got somebody already there
who knows the place enormously effective
and so I just felt like we were going to
make a very major success very quickly
we will be up and running and we already
are up and running in Chile so thank you
Karen just then final sir I think back
to the first point I want to make as the
president will say more eloquently than
I can the the idea is really to create a
new kind of University which has a
global presence so it's not just a
series of bilateral relationship with
different parts of the world it is
getting all those parts of the world to
talk to each other around the big global
challenges that that are facing us we
know those global challenges I won't
take them off everybody has their own
list but we do know is that the
knowledge base we're looking at those
things are sort of based in national
units regional units Latin America North
America Europe Far East and so forth and
until we figure out a way to create
global knowledge to talk about global
issues we will not do so well on those
global issues and so it's enormously
exciting for Columbia University
be able to say publicly for the first
time ever that we're now in the seven
major regions of the world and we're
really delighted thank you now let me
introduce a president Bollinger after
his remarks there will be a signing
ceremony at the front of the room Oh
we'll all sign the documents that will
officially inaugurate this new global
center in Santiago president bulent well
this is a truly great moment for us and
I want to say something very briefly
about the thinking that brings us here
and about the strategy that we at
Columbia have adopted and about where I
hope we'll go from here universities are
amazing places we have expertise on
almost anything you can possibly think
of and people are already amazingly
knowledgeable about parts of the world
including Latin America so we we have
great experts on on everything making
sure that those experts are able to
develop their expertise even further and
to spread that expertise and to share it
with others is a goal in itself for
University and would be I think a
sufficient justification for this new
center in Santiago but it so happens we
have another reason and the other reason
is because of the phenomena of
globalization and it's a cliche of
course to talk in terms of globalization
at this stage but I believe that every
single one of us understands that that
there are forces at work in today's
world that are creating
increasingly interdependent world
especially in the sphere of economic
activity and it's just no longer
possible for anybody whether you're an
expert in Latin America or an expert on
any other subject it's just not possible
any longer to think about your field in
all probability unless you have a deeper
knowledge of what is happening around
the world it's also extremely difficult
to get that knowledge because this is
not a case where you can simply go to
the library or turn on your computer and
read new books about it the world has
moved in our view faster it is changing
faster than our knowledge and so we have
to in universities figure out ways for
us to catch up and to perform our great
mission of doing research and education
about things that matter to the world
and to human beings the global centers
are our way of doing that in one sense
they're simply offices with wonderful
staff connected technologically all
around the world but in another sense
they will make a profound difference for
our faculty and our students and to the
people that we interact with around the
world through these centers as we
provide ourselves with serious research
and teaching to work on because it's
really by being physically present and
by working on serious problems and
issues that we can then figure out the
questions that need to be addressed in
an
academic way and then pursue them both
in our teaching and our research some
universities are setting up branch
campuses some are setting up networks of
universities some are simply doing what
they've been doing but trying to do it a
little more all those are fine we're not
doing the branch campus route we're not
doing some other routes this is our
route and the function is exactly what
you said we're trying to do that is we
are at the university are trying to
facilitate the opportunities for our
faculty and students to work with local
institutions and local and regional
institutions and people and then connect
that in a global way on serious problems
that matter so it's a it's a very very
important ambition grounded we think in
an understanding of the world and the
relation of relationship of universities
to that world and the last thing I want
to say is that this requires in every
instance because our resources at this
university are so thin and needed for so
many purposes we're pursuing all the
time we need to have friends and we need
to have people to help us understand how
to do this best and you have done that
now for us with Santiago the first in
Latin America and one of our opening
experiments in this new global network
of centers you andronica hembram enabled
us to do this and we are deeply deeply
grateful and hope you understand that
we're dead serious about this and and we
have what we think are profound reasons
behind this and so to accomplish it
together with you will be a great great
goal and a lot of fun thank you very
much
and the next few minutes of absolute
silence but for the scratching of pens
will mark the point at which we
officially inaugurate the center
you